the latest housing report shows another
record high for single-family homes and
condo sales
in june thanks for joining us i'm
christian casadas so where does that
leave those searching for a place to
call home
bianca holman is live near valley view
and alta to explain the impact
of these high numbers bianca well if you
thought the cost of homes couldn't get
any higher
you're wrong the prices are on the rise
again
out of budget for many hard-working las
vegas
so this is what we've learned so far the
median price
for existing single family homes sold in
southern nevada
is 395 thousand dollars that's up
ten thousand dollars from may's record
it's also a 21.5 increase from
june of 2020. those numbers can be
alarming for some buyers
but for those moving from higher priced
cities like la
new york or chicago it's attractive
and if you're wondering when the bubble
could burst david tina of urban
nest realty here in las vegas says
prices will eventually go down
but there are many factors like the
stock market and salaries catching up to
the cost of living
if you're a seller make your money
if you're looking to make a move now is
the time if you're a buyer
don't get discouraged there's more
inventory coming on i know there's a lot
of buyer fatigue
but it's opening up there's more options
than we've had in two months
you got to be diligent you got to have a
great realtor who's willing to work
and stay on top of the market and pounce
when it's ready
now according to las vegas realtors
there's about a one-month supply of
homes on the market right now to put
that into perspective
a six-month supply would mean that the
market is balanced
now there is a bright side experts say
that interest
interest rates are at an all-time low
reporting from near valley view and alta
bianca holman
8 news now